Let's talk about the different ways,
on which molecules can be transported
through the cell membrane.
Perhaps the most common
and the most passive of passive modes of transport
is the simple diffusion.
If we have a molecule that is small enough,
let's say it's molecular oxygen.
This molecule is small, no charge, no polarity.
Will be able to diffuse through the membrane in the direction
of its concentration gradient.
But if we have charged particles
or larger molecules,
then we need help.
The first type of help will simply be to facilitate the movement of particles
in the direction of their concentration gradient.
This is called relieved diffusion.
We have a whole separate video on the diffusion.
Some kind of diffusion
is done by opening tunnels that allow certain particles
to move in the direction of their concentration gradient.
We saw an example of such transport in the potassium ion channels.
Potassium ions accumulate inside the cell
due to the action of the sodium-potassium pump.
Let's clarify this chart,
this is the environment outside the cell,
but these channels pass potassium ions
and they move in the direction of their concentration gradient.
This will not continue until the concentration of potassium ions on both sides is equal
of the membrane, because the external environment is more positive than the interior of the cell,
we will talk about it in other videos.
But this structure is just a simple tunnel.
Some tunnels can have activation doors.
They only open if they receive a specific alert.
We see examples of these tunnels when talking about transmission of signals
along the neuron, thanks to channels regulated by the tension in the cell.
Once the voltage reaches a certain threshold,
this channel opens and scraps,
which has a higher concentration from the outside,
begins to enter the cage in the direction of its concentration gradient.
This is considered as passive transport,
this is a relaxed diffusion. Passive transport,
which allows certain particles to move in the direction
of its concentration gradient.
-
You can see that the potassium here moves in the direction
of its concentration gradient.
There is a high concentration inside
and low concentration outside the cell.
We allow him to move in the direction
of its concentration gradient.
Sodium has a high concentration outside
and low concentration inside.
This is thanks to the sodium-potassium pump.
But with this channel we allow sodium ions to move in the direction
of its concentration gradient.
Now let's talk about active transport.
Passive transport does not need energy,
to run.
At it the particles simply move in the direction of their gradient.
In active transport, however, we use energy directly,
to make something move in the opposite direction to his gradient.
Or we use energy that is created by another kind of active transport,
to help other types of particles
to move in the opposite direction to their gradient.
Let's first talk about primary active transport,
because it can be a bit easier to understand.
But none of the modes of transport is very complex.
When we talk about animal cells,
a very good example of active transport is
sodium-potassium pump.
It is extremely important to establish
membrane potential of rest.
Furthermore, the concentration gradients,
which it creates
are very important.
The sodium-potassium pump pumps
sodium ions outside the cell,
contrary to their concentration gradient.
Sodium ions already have
higher concentration outside,
but the pump continues to export them out of the cage.
To do this, she uses the ATP.
It degrades ATP to ADP and phosphate group.
Hydrolyzes it.
Therefore, sometimes the sodium-potassium pump is called ATPase.
This is an enzyme that helps break down ATP.
But the sodium-potassium pump uses this energy to pump sodium ions
outside the cell and potassium ions to the inside of the cell.
Then we will see that the sodium ions, pumped out of the cage,
form a reserve of potential energy.
An electrochemical gradient has begun,
which can later be used to carry out secondary active transport.
We'll talk about this in seconds.
This is the situation in animal cells.
The analogue of plant cells, fungi and prokaryotes
is the protonated ATPase or protonic nodule,
which does the same thing but instead
to do it in two directions,
she pumped protons only
outside the cell, contrary to their concentration gradient.
Even if there is a higher concentration of protons
outside the cell rather than in it, the pump will continue to export them from the crate.
To do this, you must use the ATP to change it
conformation in the appropriate manner.
For this reason, this is called
proton ATPase, and this is called sodium-potassium ATPase,
our friend the sodium-potassium pump.
This is called proton ATPase.
You can not see these two structures in the same cage.
I'll draw a line here,
this will be a plant cell or a sponge, etc.
This will be an animal cage.
Both proton and sodium-potassium pumps use energy.
They use the ATF directly to transport different things
contrary to their concentration gradient,
so we call this process an active transport.
Because we have these concentration gradients
or these electrochemical gradients,
they can also be used in other forms of active transport.
This is called secondary active transport.
This is my painting here
the simporter. It is a symptom of sodium and glucose.
It uses sodium ion
in the direction of their concentration gradient.
This gradient was created thanks to
sodium-potassium pump.
Sodium ions move in the direction of their concentration gradient,
but the energy from this movement can be used.
You can imagine if we put a small wheel
under a waterfall he will turn it.
Similarly, the flow of sodium ions is used to transport glucose
contrary to its concentration gradient.
Glucose already exists
high concentration here
and low here. But the sympatter carries glucose
contrary to its concentration gradient.
We are talking about this in other videos too.
Another example of secondary active transport
are the anti-supporters.
In the symporter, which is a co-transporter, both types of particles
go in the same direction, although one kind
moves in the direction of its concentration gradient
and drives the transportation,
and the other type moves back to
its concentration gradient.
This is an active transport.
With antiparts, the two different types of particles move in opposite directions.
We can not have a sodium-calcium anti-
where the sodium moves in the direction of
its concentration gradient,
which drives calcium ion extraction
outside the cell, contrary to their concentration gradient.
And repeat again, whenever something moves
contrary to its concentration gradient,
in this case these are the calcium ions,
we have active transport.
But because sodium ions
and calcium ions move in different directions,
we call this protein anti-
while this one is a symphon.
Now you might wonder if the sodium-potassium pump
is not an antiporter.
Sodium and potassium ions run in different directions.
The difference is that here
we have primary active transport.
For the sodium-potassium pump
both types of particles move back to
its concentration gradient.
And with a real anti-
we have secondary active transport.
One particle moves in the direction of its concentration gradient,
which delivers energy
to transfer the other kind of particles back to their concentration gradient.
I hope this video gave you a basic idea
for different modes of transport
and about how much
complex, beautiful and enchanting
are cell membranes and all
various cell functions.